こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです。
皆さん、僕は今までいろんな人の眠りを妨げてきました。
で、眠りを妨げる方法としては、
もちろんいろんな方法があると思うんですけども、
僕は基本的に音を使って眠りを妨げてきました。
で、今回も音を使って眠りを妨げようと思いうんですけども、
なかなかですね、ここまでくると、特殊な音とかをさがすのが難しくて
もう多分ねぶっちゃけ銅鑼とかね、銅鑼とか
あの、、、
銅鑼だわ。
もう銅鑼とかが最強レベルにうるさかったのかなとか思ってきたんですけども
まあ、あの手この手で色々考えたあげく僕が発明した
これまででおそらくなんですけども、
準備するものはこちら！
そしてこちら
雷管っていうのかなー？
音花火の一種だと思うんですけども
位置について　よーい　ドン　バンってやるやつの火薬の部分に当たります。
１つ１００個入りなので今回こちらに１０箱、１０００発準備させていただきました。
この前バンってやったときに思ったんですけども、あれ実はただねなんか銃の先にこういうのがあって
それで火薬を置いたところにバンって　なんか　トリガー引くのでバンってやってるだけなんすよ。
意外と単純です、あの運動会のよーいドンは。
運動会のよーいドンはこいつに向かってなんか変な引き金引いてバンってなってるだけなんで、
そのバンをこれでバンってやれば、もっとバンってなるんじゃないんですかねー？
って結論に至ったので
すべてのスケールを大きくして、
今回はハンマーの先っぽに雷管を１０００粒つけれるだけつけまくって
せーの、ボガーン
イーェイ
つけていきます。
えーこれ結構これやばいと思うんだけどなー。
試しにちょっと一個でやってみましょうか。
一個だと大体こんな音です。
いきます。
あれたってる？音
うわーうえうわうわうわー
待って煙出てるじゃん。
熱いあつっ　焦げちゃった。
そういえばこれ花火かー。
行きますよ行きますよー。
こうやると、
じゃ、つけていきます！
ひとまず重ねまくってなるべく音花火が一気に出るような状況を作ってあげます。
オッケできたぞー。
これで５００発入り
よし、できました。
これで５００、５００です。
これをここにセットします。
よし、これでつけます。
というわけで完成しました。
まあガンハンマーみたいなところでしょう。
完全にガンハンマー。
この先っぽに音が鳴る花火が１０００発いまセットされております。
近すぎるとたぶん耳が持っていかれるんでちょっと離れたぐらいの位置でこのガンハンマーで下で寝てるやつを起こしてあげようと思います。
ではいこう！
うおーっ！？
えー！？
モ↑ヤ↓モ↑ヤ↓モ↑ヤ↓モ↑ヤ↓モ↑ヤ↓モ↑ヤ↓モ↑ヤ↓モ↑ヤ↓
モォ↑　ヤ↑シ↑モ↑ヤァ↓シィ↓
モ↓ヤ↓シ↓モォ↑　ヤ↑シ↑モ↑ヤァ↓シィ↓
モ↓ヤ↓シ↓モォ↑　ヤァ↓シ↓モ↓　ヤ↓シ↑モ↓ヤァ↑シィ↓
モ↑ヤ↓モ↑ヤ↓モ↑ヤ↓モ↑ヤッ↓
モッ！モッ！ヤッ！シッ！★
おはよう♪
えー？
はははっ（ｗｗｗ）
いやいや破壊力よ。
音えっ、音どうだった？
いやもうなんか家が壊れる
はじめ）ｗｗｗｗｗｗ　寝てた人）ｗｗｗｗ
すごかったよでも。
いやたぶん過去最高のパワーだったよ。
ゴホッゴホッゴホッ、、、
みんな、、、
マネしないでね♪
バ～イ♪
ｗｗｗ